e proprio vero i computer ci circondano
ma siamo veramente soddisfatti di questi
computer computer sono dietro ad
internet sembra quasi magia sono dietro
alle transazioni bancarie al
coordinamento dei voli nel cielo e sono
dietro alla gestione dei magazzini di
supermercati dove andiamo tutti i giorni
che noi affolliamo esistono computer
potentissimi come questo che vedete qui
dietro di me è il più potente
supercomputer al mondo di proprietà di
un centro di ricerca americano in grado
di fare un numero di calcoli spaventoso
quindi direi che possiamo essere
decisamente soddisfatti di come
funzionano questi oggetti
eppure ci sono delle cose che questi
computer non sanno fare
cerchiamo di capire cosa non sanno fare
questi computer vi porto alcuni esempi
il primo esempio riguarda la
ricostruzione su computer in maniera
esatta di alcune tipologie di molecole
non serve sempre fare la
rappresentazione esatta della molecola
per studiarla nella sua completezza
in molte case tante proprietà della
molecole riusciamo a dedurre anche se
non abbiamo una rappresentazione esatta
ma se avessimo la rappresentazione
esatta beh sapremmo veramente fare molto
nella scienza dei materiali nella
farmacologia nello studio del nostro
corpo e della natura
ebbene cerchiamo di quantificarlo in bit
i bit sono quei portatori di
informazione che fanno funzionare
appunto i computer sono dei piccoli
interruttori che possono valere 01 e
messi uno dietro all'altro formano i
programmi fuori
le informazioni che noi ci scambiamo
quotidianamente con i nostri cellulari e
bene prendiamo ad esempio la molecola
d'acqua per poterla rappresentare
modellizzare come diciamo noi su un
computer
c'è bisogno di 10.000 bit sono pochi le
immagini che vuoi scattate con i vostri
cellulari richiedono molti più bit di
questi andiamo un po avanti guardiamo
per esempio le molecole simili a quella
dell'etanolo sono un pochettino più
complesse come vedete dalla formula e
hanno bisogno di mille miliardi di bit
sembrano tanti ma non sono così tanti
riusciamo ancora a gestirli vi ricordo
che abbiamo delle macchine come quella
che abbiamo appena visto nei centri di
ricerca ma se facciamo un passettino un
pochino più avanti vediamo ad esempio
una molecola come la caffeina che in
quest'ora della serata potrebbe anche
esserci utile
ebbene qui andiamo su 10 alla 48 intanto
cosa vuol dire 10 alla 48 vuol dire che
c'è un 1 e poi ci sono 48 zeri dietro
già è difficile immaginarsi un numero
fatto con 148 zeri sicuramente qualcuno
qualche zero cielo perdiamo ma
sicuramente non riusciamo a immaginare
quanto possa essere grande o computer
che è in grado di gestire tutti questi
bit
ebbene vuoto per pieno dovremmo fare un
computer grande come mezza luna per
poter gestire un calcolo di questo tipo
in maniera esatta
non sto dicendo che non siamo in grado
di conoscere le proprietà della caffeina
sto dicendo che se la volessimo
rappresentare esattamente e quindi
studiarla in maniera molto più
approfondita e bene servirebbe un
calcolatore enorme quello che vi ho
fatto vedere prima sarebbe una briciola
a confronto
ma andiamo su molecole un pochettino più
interessanti per la farmacologia per il
funzionamento del nostro corpo è bene
vediamo dei numeri spaventosi 10 all 82
alla 86
non abbiamo idea di che cosa si è bene
sono più di quanti atomi stimiamo
esistano all'interno dell'universo
dovremmo costruire un computer grande
quanto tutto l'universo per poter
rappresentare la molecola della
penicillina sembra uno sforzo enorme
ebbene vi porto un secondo esempio in
questo primo esempio l'applicazione
pratica è chiara dobbiamo cercare di
capire come funzionano le molecole per
creare nuovi materiali e portare dei
vantaggi in ambito medico però il
calcolo ci sfugge come si fa a simulare
una molecola su un calcolatore adesso
invece vi faccio un esempio in cui il
calcolo è chiarissimo eccolo qua allora
l'operazione che va dal 3 per 5 al 15 si
chiama moltiplicazione
l'operazione che dal 15 va dal 3 per
cinque si chiama scomposizione in numeri
primi le facciamo tutte e due alle
elementari i computer che abbiamo le
sanno fare sia in una direzione che
nell'altra
aumentiamo un po le cifre
allora noi non sappiamo fare nessuna
delle due il computer di computer che
abbiamo oggi anche quel grosso
cervellone che vi ho fatto vedere prima
sono tutti abbastanza in grado sono
molto rapidi a fare la moltiplicazione
ovvero l'operazione che va dai due
numeri che avete a destra a quello che
avete a sinistra sono estremamente
inefficienti a fare l'operazione
contraria ci mettono centinaia di
migliaia di anni
e beh qui la domanda sorge spontanea
cosa ci interessa di questa cosa che ci
interessa molto perché noi questa
incapacità dei computer che abbiamo oggi
la sfruttiamo tutti i giorni la
sfruttiamo per proteggere i nostri dati
dietro c'è la cosiddetta crittografia
ok noi ripetiamo i nostri dati sensibili
con delle chiavi di questo tipo
essendo certi che anche il più grande
supercomputer del mondo ci metterà
tantissimo tempo troppo tempo la carta
di credito scadrà molto prima di quando
qualcuno che riuscirà a decriptare il
suo numero e quindi anche in questo caso
ci sono dei calcoli che i computer
attuali non fanno fare in questo caso
però l'abbiamo sfruttato al nostro
vantaggio e siamo molto contenti che non
li sappiano fare da quanto tempo ci
siamo accorti che il computer così come
alcuni calcoli non strafare a da
tantissimo d'altronde il computer a uno
strumento come tutti qualsiasi tipo di
strumento è utile a fare alcune cose e
altre le fa meno bene qui ad esempio c'è
il buon richard feynman premio nobel per
la fisica il quale aveva avuto
chiaramente l'intuizione dicendo beh la
natura funziona in base alle leggi della
meccanica quantistica ci sarà bisogno di
un computer che funziona in seguendo le
leggi della meccanica quantistica per
poterla simulare che d'altronde quello
che abbiamo tentato di fare nel primo
esempio è proprio simulare la natura
delle molecole questo lui lo ha detto
quaranta anni fa
cerchiamo un po di seguire il suo
ragionamento
abbiamo detto che i computer come li
abbiamo oggi ragionano in questo modo
sono degli interruttori che dicono sì e
no
le mettiamo uno di seguito all'altro ne
mettiamo migliaia milioni miliardi e
facciamo tutti i programmi che noi
abbiamo però il portatore di
informazione base può contenere solo
questa semplice informazione 0 o 1
esistono delle particelle meccanica
quantistica che noi possiamo mettere in
uno stato particolare che in grado di
contenere un quantitativo di formazione
enorme
si chiama stato di sovrapposizione
quantistica
ebbene questo noi possiamo prenderlo
come bit quantistico o qubit come viene
chiamato in un qubit io potenzialmente
riesco a mettere tanta informazione che
può essere rappresentata come un punto
su una sfera facciamo un esempio pratico
se io dovessi inserire all'interno di un
beat codificare all'interno di un bit
la mia posizione sulla terra quello che
posso fare è dire se mi trovo
nell'emisfero nord o nell'emisfero sud
non posso dire altro in un solo bit
ebbene se io avessi a disposizione un
qubit potrei inserire all'interno di
questo qubit la mia esatta posizione sul
globo capita bene quanta più
informazione riusciamo a a inserire
ebbene esistono altre proprietà della
meccanica quantistica che ci permettono
di inserire all'interno di un grosso
numero di cubito un quantitativo di
informazioni immensa ed è proprio quella
che ci serve per risolvere i problemi di
cui abbiamo parlato prima
e questa è la teoria sono passati tanti
anni da quando fai mano ha detto quella
frase da quando i ricercatori che
studiano la computazione quantistica che
si basa su questi principi hanno tentato
di realizzare un computer quantistico
vero e la notizia è che oggi abbiamo un
computer quantistico prima cosa
qual è il computer quantistico
se voi andate su internet cercare
computer quantistico immagini
trovate per la maggior parte delle volte
qualche cosa che è più simile a ciò che
vedete a destra è quello il computer
quantistico no il computer quantistico
in realtà è quello di sinistra è il
processore sul quale si trovano i qubit
di cui abbiamo parlato prima che ci sono
voluti quasi 40 anni per riuscire a
realizzarlo allora chiediamoci che cos'è
quello a destra
eccolo a destra è un frigorifero quella
destra è un grosso frigorifero che serve
a portare alla parte inferiore quel
cilindro che vedete in fondo a una
temperatura che è più bassa della
temperatura del dello spazio
interstellare
sembra assurdo ma è così perché nello
spazio interstellare c'è ancora un
rimasuglio della temperatura
dell'esplosione del big bang vi sembrerà
strano ma è così è successo tanto tempo
fa ma c'è ancora un minimo di calore che
viene da lì ecco qui noi dobbiamo
toglierlo perché dobbiamo toglierlo
dobbiamo toglierlo perché il qubit che
avete visto prima e i qubit soprattutto
quando sono insieme sono delle delle
strutture estremamente delicate
qualsiasi tipo di interazione che
proviene dall'esterno o dall'interno gli
fa perdere tutte quelle belle proprietà
che abbiamo visto prima e quindi quella
capacità di immagazzinare un grande
numero informazioni e poi poterci fare
dei calcoli sopra e li fa diventare dei
semplici bit che possiamo usare senza
dover utilizzare questi mega frigoriferi
e quindi noi lo abbiamo questo oggetto è
già possiamo pensare che già stiamo
applicando lo per studiare alcune
molecole ancora non sono dei computer
quantistici enormi anno i più potenti
anno circa 50 cubito al loro interno
alcuni di questi sono a disposizione di
tutti
chiunque può tramite internet o usare
dei piccoli computer quantistici e
cominciare a programmarli e ripeto lo
stiamo facendo per le molecole lo stiamo
facendo per esempio per la simulazione
degli scenari economici ma allora è la
crittografia come la mettiamo sulla
crittografia io ho una notizia buona e
una cattiva la notizia cattiva è che noi
già conosciamo il programma che serve
per fare la scomposizione in numeri
primi su un computer quantistico e
sappiamo che la fa in maniera
rapidissima addirittura lo sappiamo da
tanto tempo
questo è un algoritmo che ha scritto
peterson nel 1994 20 anni prima che
qualcuno costruisse questo caso la
notizia buona è che sappiamo che quella
algoritmo quel programma per girare ha
bisogno di un processore quantistico con
qualche milione di qubit ebbene noi
crediamo che sarà possibile costruire
questo oggetto ma probabilmente ci
vorranno 10 20 anni avremo tutto il
tempo per studiare sistemi crittografici
che siano in grado di resistere ad un
attacco di questo tipo è già lo stiamo
facendo bene è estremamente emozionante
per noi che ci lavoriamo partecipare a
questa rivoluzione del mondo
dell'informatica
a me piace
fare il parallelo con una rivoluzione
che c'è stata nel mondo dei trasporti
pensiamo agli inizi del 900 i fratelli
wright dopo secoli che leonardo aveva
disegnato le prime macchine volanti i
fratelli wright cominciavano a far
volare i primi velivoli non avevano idea
di quello che sarebbe venuto nel futuro
non avevano idea di come avremmo
viaggiato noi e come si sarebbero
spostate le merci sicuramente non
avevano idea che dopo 60 anni saremmo
andati sulla luna
ebbene stiamo vivendo nell'informatica
una rivoluzione pari a questa si stanno
aprendo nuove professioni servono
ingegneri per costruire questi oggetti
servono informatici per costruire nuovi
linguaggi di programmazione per questi
oggetti
servono programmatori per scrivere i
programmi che gireranno su questi
oggetti e dunque benvenuti in una nuova
era dell'informatica
[Applauso]
[Musica]